it has been a hundred years since the
end of World War one the Armistice
signed in 1918 was supposed to bring the
world together but a group of American
soldiers who were fighting for freedom
and democracy had yet to experience
those ideals in their own country on the
fourth floor of the new Smithsonian
Museum so just how segregated was a
military it was completely segregated is
a tribute to American veterans the
freedmen of the Massachusetts 54th the
Buffalo Soldiers the Tuskegee Airmen and
a regiment with an unforgettable
nickname do we know why these guys were
called the Harlem Hellfighters I really
don't think we do it whether it was the
French whether it was the Germans or
whether it was the American press crew
Walski Salter is a guest curator at the
Museum of african-american history and
culture the Harlem Hellfighters is a
name no matter where the origin came
from sticks to the heart of the way
these men served and fought a band of
brothers who faced adversity from the
start
where are they sent to be trained in
Spartanburg South Carolina you have
these northern African Americans going
down in the heart of this era where
there are these riots clashes between
white Americans and African Americans
among the first American troops to
arrive in France their first few months
weren't spent fighting digging ditches
digging latrine digging latrines making
roads building camps why well there are
many reasons but I think a part of it
there was a political pool and then
there was this issue some of the white
Americans did not want African American
units to fight but the European allies
were desperate for fighters so
commanding general john pershing handed
over the all-black unit to the French
the 369th served 191 days in combat more
than any other American troops the germ
saw that these men fought ferociously on
the battlefield some weren't just
fighting Lieutenant James Europe led the
Hellfighters regiment band the Greek was
credited with bringing jazz to the
French every regiment had a band but
there was no band like a 360 night band
and they combined this new music that
was heard from the very time they set
foot off the ship and they were sent on
a tour around France but the battlefield
was where they made their name their
most famous act of heroism happened in
May of 1918 privates Henry Johnson and
Needham robbers were sentries at an
isolated outpost when they were attacked
by at least a dozen Germans and so
during that fight while Johnson runs out
of bullets
he's throwing grenades he's using his
rifle as a club and he ends up using his
bolo knife he also prevents Germans from
dragging his buddy
Needham Roberts away Johnson and Roberts
would become the first American soldiers
of any race to receive the krodha care
when of Francis highest awards for valor
that was the night that the bravery the
patriotism and the service of what
African Americans were capable of and
willing to do for their country became
known throughout the world more than a
hundred and fifty other Hellfighters
were given the Croix de Guerre including
Lawrence McVeigh senior this one is his
military uniform he looks so proud he
does Geena McVeigh is the corporals
granddaughter when did you discover the
true story about 2004-5 I went to the
car dealership to get my car repaired it
was a gentleman in uniform sitting next
to me waiting for his car so I thanked
him for his service and I said oh my
grandfather fought in the war he goes he
did I said yeah well one
and I said he won this French meadow he
said what I said he won a French meadow
he goes well can I ask you a question I
said yes goes was your grandfather a
black man I said yes he said was the
meadow the quad the gear I said yes he
said do you know what you have I'm like
a metal he said no you have history
McVeigh contacted the Smithsonian and
was asked to bring in her grandfather's
belongings I said it's all yours
and they they're like really I said yeah
I donated a haul despite enduring more
days in combat than any other American
troops despite being the first Allies to
reach the Rhine River despite no member
ever being taken prisoner the American
government refused them an important
honor they were not allowed to march in
the victory parade US government said no
if they can't March this was in France
but in February of 1919 the hell
fighters were allowed to parade up New
York City's Fifth Avenue to Harlem you
see the pride of these men and when you
watch that formation you know what's
there an even greater sense of pride
came in 2015 when one of the hell
fighters received the ultimate award
from America's first black president the
President of the United States of
America has awarded in the name of
Congress the Medal of Honor to private
Henry Johnson United States Army it's
just amazing that all the things that
the African American community has done
with the weight of not being good enough
on their back they didn't let that stop
them they went ahead and they fought for
what they thought was right
what's great about the herstory is she
was just thanking a veteran for his
service we got so much more and it was a
white veteran yeah
which goes to the point I want to give a
shout out to Colonel William Hayward he
was the officer over the 369th this
all-black unit he gave them respect
he gave them honor and what he did was
bring attention to them he's one of the
reasons why they were able to
at that parade up to Harlem well and why
many people believe the Croix de Guerre
was bestowed upon them and I love what
Gina McVeigh said with it it said do you
know what you have you have
[Laughter]